Так.
Коли дивишся на сьогоднішні можливості, я вважаю, що дуже важливо також запитати:
а яка ж дорожня карта? Наскільки
кращими стають ці системи,
наскільки
складнішими
будуть circuit, які ми зможемо виконувати?
Для цього ми розробили дуже важливу метрику,
яку називаємо квантовим об'ємом.
Іноді в популярній пресі можна прочитати або почути
про кількість qubit як
міру прогресу.
Скажу відверто:
просто кількість qubit у машині — це не
хороша міра прогресу.
Прогрес треба вимірювати
рівнем складності circuit, який ти можеш виконати.
Qubit і ці хороші машини сьогодні ще не ідеальні —
у них є помилки, що виникають через зв'язок
системи із зовнішнім світом.
Сама потужність цих qubit —
заплутаність та інші властивості —
водночас робить їх і потужними,
і вразливими до взаємодії
та зв'язку із зовнішнім світом.
Тому потрібно знижувати рівень помилок,
одночасно збільшуючи кількість qubit.
Саме це й показано тут.
Найкраще рухатися по діагоналі —
а квантовий об'єм є мірою, яка поєднує
обидві ці метрики та деякі ключові додаткові показники.